hi I'm Florence rose I'm a makeup artist
and a model if you want to find out how
to create the perfect red lip thank you
for watching to create the perfect red
lip I'm first taking it cosmetics lip
liner in shades itself which is a
perfect true red I am lining the outline
of my lips starting with the top lip and
going on to the bottom i blend this out
slightly as you don't want too harsh red
line I really like this product as it's
very creamy and makes it much easier to
apply to the lip other products which
can be quite dry so once I've lined my
lips I'm now taking fenty beauty's
astana lip paint in shade uncensored
this is a perfect true red as well and I
like to apply this with the brush that
comes with as it's perfect to apply with
it's very creamy and this is a great
product to powers it's very cool toned
and a proper true red which goes nicely
with my fair skin tone and with my pink
hair for me especially with my dry skin
[Music]
for more videos like this subscribe to
glamour UK's YouTube channel
[Music]